Eric is with us in Olympia Washington
IRA how are you hey I'm doing well sir
how are you better than I deserve what's
up hey I'm have a little bit of a
disagreement with my wife I was hoping
you could tip the skills and give us
some outside perspective I want she
wants to move up in car I'd like to save
up and pay cash for the vehicle however
she thinks that having a larger savings
is okay she wants to finance the vehicle
and she's okay with having a car payment
if it means we have a larger savings and
I tried to explain to her about you know
depreciation and tell her why it's
stupid to get debt but I think she needs
to hear from somebody else so I was
hoping you could speak to that a little
bit okay the thing I've noticed after 30
years of doing this is that different
classes of people regardless of race
different socio-economic rungs on the
ladder do different stupid things poor
people the rough into town play the
lottery more often than anybody else
lottery tickets are almost all sold in
poor zip codes payday lenders eight
hundred percent Interest rent to own
title pawning you don't see these places
in the rich into town you know why
because rich people don't do them that's
how they got rich okay in the middle
class middle class struggles with credit
cards with student loans with car
payments and with whole life life
insurance and they give their money they
give their money the middle class
ensures that they're never going to be
anything but middle class by being in
debt to credit card companies and car
companies and borrowing and using whole
life policies which are a complete
ripoff and in credit cards and so the
and then you look at the upper class and
go okay what do they do well we want to
mimic that because 90% of millionaires
in America started with nothing and
became millionaires they didn't inherit
their money they're not crooks and
they're not professional athletes or
regular people they just did things
different so what do they do when I'm
interviewing people on the
millionaire theme hour for example I
asked them how many new cars of you
bought before you are a millionaire they
almost always told me one or two and it
was the worst mistake of my life
how much did debt cause you borrowing
money cause you to become wealthy they
almost always say oh no I never borrowed
any money that was a blessing every time
I borrowed money it held me back from
building wealth and so that's what rich
people say and what's your broke
brother-in-law thinks or what some
journalism student with eighty two
thousand dollars in student loan debt
writes on market watch I couldn't care
less about or is a you know a guest
contributor from motley fool and they
meant fool for sure I mean you know I
don't care if you're broke what your
opinion is about money you follow me so
we follow the money here show me the
money
it's a jury McGuire moment and if rich
people say the best way to get out of
the best way to become wealthy is stay
out of debt then we do what rich people
say because that's how they got there
you can't you know there's just no
disputing that and the bottom line is
this the average car payment America now
this month we got last month we got data
that it's now five hundred and one
dollars a month is the average okay $500
a month invested from age 30 to age 70
and the decent growth stock mutual fund
in a Roth IRA is over five point six
million dollars that's what a car
payment costs you it's five million
bucks over the scope of your life and so
that that's why you know rich people
don't have car payments because that's
how they got rich and so your the point
is your most powerful wealth building
tool is your income and you can't make
middle-class mistakes with money and be
anything but middle-class there's
nothing nothing immoral are in noble
about being middle-class it's a matter
of if you if you eat the same food fat
people you're gonna be fat duh you know
and if you want to be skinny find out
what skinny people eat and eat what they
eat I wish I could do more of that I
don't do enough of it myself but I mean
it's still at this great example right
find out somebody's been married 50
years and they have a fabulous marriage
and they can't keep their hands off
each other so what did you guys do
because other people I know about killed
themselves and I want to know how you
get a marriage like that you know and so
I'm going to talk to people who are
winning at something and do what they do
and not somebody that's just got a
feeling or an opinion because that'll
make you broke your whole life so all of
that is how I came to the conclusion
that and through the faith lens but the
borrower is slave to the lender and I
can't find anywhere in Scripture it says
to get a car payment although deep Jesus
did say they were all in one Accord
right what a bum Shh okay okay so all of
that to say there's no possible way you
should ever buy a car with a car payment
I would ride a bicycle before I had a
car with a car payment and it's not
forever I'm just gonna save up and pay
for it but it sounds like you have the
cash to pay cash for the car you want
we're not far off we have about seven
thousand dollars above our emergency
fund and I would like to spend a few
more months saving up the additional
amount but she's I guess little anxious
doesn't want to work or doesn't want to
wait she commutes an hour each way to
work currently and so it's right
understand being a more cautious it's
harder her card is she driving now she
drives the 2001 Mustang right now how
many miles are just about two hundred
thousand I would move up in corn now I
agree with her but I would do it with
the seven thousand in cash and then save
up and do it again next year
okay sorry both of you get your way I
want her to have the nicer car she wants
but I'm with you she waits till next
year to get it in the meantime you can
move her up about three times but good a
car she's in now or four times as good a
car she can now with that car plus seven
grand right right well you know honestly
I didn't think of it that way and that's
a good idea sure I sure appreciate your
help Dave you know but the big thing
here is if you get the Y that whole
diatribe I went on well if you get the
why behind why you don't do car payments
then it's not a matter of if I do them
because I'm not going to do them but how
do I work around it and still accomplish
some of the goals once I take car
payments off the table other creative
answers start you know like staging it
like we're talking about
coming up on the table but the typical
person just goes I wanted the moogle boy
mmm and then writer scratch their head
while they're broke their whole life
because they're giving it all the
stinking Ford Motor Credit or Lexus
Motor Credit or Toyota credit or
Chrysler creditor credit it is
somebody's getting credit and in you you
know and so it's a problem it's a real
problem but just figure out a way to
work around it hey I'm with her I think
she's driving a piece of crap I'm an
hour two hours a day and she's Riedel
rattling along the road going when's
this thing gonna leave me stranded out
here in Washington because it kind of
gets cold there in the winter yeah I'm
getting her a better car or give her
yours and you drive the crap on the too
if you got a better car by the way that
is federal law mom gets the good car was
it our house anyway so but I tell you
what man you guys the car payment is
truly the mantra of the middle class and
we have said many times on here that you
know the credit card everybody credit
cards are interesting everybody knows
credit cards suck but everybody keeps
using them so we're at the stage with
the credit card that we were with the
cigarette about 1985 everybody was
disgusted with cigarettes everybody knew
they killed you but nobody did anything
about it but somewhere around 1985 it
became like not cool at all to smoke
anymore because it kills you and it's
stupid and you smell bad things think
things true credit card repair Carter is
the cigarette of the financial world and
it's heading that direction it just may
take another decade to get completely
uncool I'm gonna help anything else to
do this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
now
[Applause]
[Music]